you know
it's kind of reminiscent i'd love to
hear actually your opinion this is
reminiscent of the goodwill hunting
story what do you think about that that
movie that movie it's
about it's mit it's yeah i guess when i
think of that film
i think about matt damon as a young guy
risking everything giving up harvard
i think you know probably the most
accomplished group of people in the
world are people who choose to give up
harvard voluntarily
it's beautiful right that's true bigger
than harvard you know ives was one of
these people
um bill gates of course uh
and then oddly uh zuckerberg what
zuckerberg
but then uh steve jobs gave up a read
and read
is like the weirdest craziest college in
the world people should pay much more
attention to read and i'm sorry it's
going through a hard time at the moment
but what it was before the current
craziness is really an interesting story
irregardless as we say in the 617 area
code um
i think that a lot about a lot of my
reaction is to the the real story of
matt damon
having this vision and being the young
guy to pull it off
and you know i also think about robin
williams trying to explore
heart through this lens of acting
and you know as you and i you've hung
out with comedians they
know that they are a screwed up bunch of
people they do
they'll they're proud about it they
really are
the idea that robin williams who i saw
many years ago when i was in l.a
in the comedy clubs around here you know
he was a
straight-up crazy dysregulated genius in
tremendous pain
and his desire to do it earnestly
through acting
rather than constantly by just sniping
you know or or being a clown or or
showing us how
fast his mind worked relative to ours um
i i was really moved by i thought that
he he brought some authenticity
and took a huge risk for a comedian to
be that real
and again like you said it doesn't
always have to be but in that case the
madness and the genius were
neighbors that one couldn't have been
any other way
yeah no because his mind you the thing
about seeing him in a comedy club
was that he would react to random
stimulus in the environment
you know it could be a heckler sometimes
you almost got the feeling that he
wanted a heckler because it was
it gave him something to play against
right he was just he was infinitely
instantly inventive
but i actually to me the best robin
williams
is as he got closer and closer to the
end of his life
because there was a sadness and he's
almost
fighting the sadness with this
improvisational like hit the weapons he
has
is this wit and humor and this dancing
that he does with language
but and then sometimes when you just
fall silent
you can see the sadness and and
i don't know there's something so
beautiful about that it's like this bird
with a broken wing that's like
trying to fly you know and it's getting
older and older and
i mean those he would have made a one
hell of a podcast guess i'll tell you
i'll tell you that that's a sad
um yeah i have some sadness that i
really do think that part of
what we call podcasting is actually just
getting to know a soul
right over and over again like yeah
maybe the idea is that this is talking
about
depression and sadness and
heavy feelings is not an american
specialty
seeing that in context with the beauty
of life is a russian specialty
like it is very much special
it sounds like a diner menu what yeah
what the russian special
a big scoop of ice cream with tons of
depression
you